hey what's going on everybody today's
video will be another breakdown of the
updated version of the plot leaked I ran
a poll on Twitter for you guys and this
was what the majority of you guys wanted
to most so let's get things started
today and let's break down season 7
episode 6 which will be the episode
right before the finale during season 7
which is typically Game of Thrones most
explosive episode so buckle your seat
belts ladies and gentlemen two shits
about to get crazy and I just want to
say first that I have no idea how much
of this will come through but if even
half of this episode turns out to be
true then this is going to be the
greatest episode in television history
in my opinion but let's read through
this and see what is even possible
season 7 episode 6 starts off with Jon
Snow Jorah Mormont Theon Greyjoy Davos
Seaworth and Gendry arriving at Castle
black Lord Commander edie
and Jon Snow reunited edie tells John
that the others arrived earlier that day
which were their Brotherhood without
banners who were also with tormund
Giantsbane and Brienne of Tarth
okay now let's break down this part and
personally I think this is wrong
Jon Snow is going to arrive with these
guys to the wall but I do not think it's
going to be a Castle black it's actually
going to be at eastwatch-by-the-sea just
like I reported on back in October the
cast and crew have been in Iceland
filming these scenes on the beach with
the black sands where they are going to
touch ground first and the original leak
said that they would go to
eastwatch-by-the-sea and considering
everything else for this episode has
appeared to be accurate then I'm just
going to assume that this is going to be
accurate to joining company are going to
sail up to the wall and if they do make
it out of the north with a captured
white they will probably transport the
white by boat and take it around the
wall not through the wall which may
explain how they're able to get that
white south poor man has arrived in
Iceland and so has Jon Snow he's also
came back so that he could film scenes
on and around this beach in Davos Jorah
ginjury Thoreau's and the Hound are all
up there as well and they're going to be
the core group of characters that
at the wall and beyond the wall next
season but I highly doubt that Theon and
bran are going to be there I think they
would have been spotted around town or
on set by now and none of the confirmed
reports have ever mentioned either one
of these characters being there nor has
any of the photos of them been seen in
Iceland or Belfast so I wouldn't expect
to see Theon and bran
beyond the wall next season but overall
we will get a scene like this but it
will be at eastwatch-by-the-sea in bran
and Theon will not be there in my
opinion okay the next scene says Gendry
forgives forests of Muir and beric
Dondarrion for selling him to Melisandre
barek also tells everyone that Jon Snow
is azor Ahai which torment and Davos
agree John tells the Brotherhood without
banners and the Nights Watch about his
plan to capture a white Davos stays
behind and writes Daenerys a letter
saying that if she comes and helps John
then they will lay down his title as
king in the north then John and Davos
give everyone some dragonglass that they
were treated from Dragonstone then the
wildlings the Nights Watch and the
Brotherhood without banners
head north of the wall alright I just
want to stop right here because this is
a huge scene that's coming up next so I
just want to break down what we have so
far and first I do think entry is going
to forgive for us and barek at least I
think he's going to forgive them for the
time being because we know from spoiler
photos that they are filming together
and they will be going on this dangerous
mission together
so there are going to need to be
civilized for right now and second is
very going to say that John is a Zora hi
I really don't know it's kind of hard to
predict what the dialogue is going to be
next season but my only guess is that if
the conversation comes up about John
being resurrected then I could see
people start to call him that
and considering Davos and tormund know
he came back from the dead then I am
sure that they think he had someone
pretty damn special okay third does John
tell the others about his plan to
capture a white I think that'd be pretty
obvious and the most logical thing to do
I know if it was me I wouldn't want to
lead people blindly into a mission as
dangerous as this is going to be I
would want them to be prepared for the
worst that way we are all in the same
page when we do this I think they need
to plan this thing out as if there's
like Navy SEALs going behind enemy lines
to capture an enemy with high target
value that way they can complete this
mission and get everyone out of lives
but that's just my opinion
so I think he is going to tell them what
he wants to do in 4th will Davos write
to Daenerys and tell her that John said
he's going to lay down his title as king
in the north
as long as she comes up north and helps
well Davos just learned how to start
reading like two days ago so I don't
know if he's already capable of writing
letters on his own and without anyone
ripping my head off in the comment
section can I just say that I hate the
sound of John offering to give up his
title as king I would think if John
offered to help her with the Lannisters
the Daenerys should help John up north
if this is true and John does lay down
his title I'm wondering how sanso is
going to react to this most people
already assume Shaun's that has a
problem with John being named the king
so how is she going to react if John
gives up all their power to another
woman I don't think she would appreciate
that not until she got the note Daenerys
at least and understood exactly why John
had to do this but again this is just my
two cents
but then it says Davos and John give
everyone dragonglass
that they got from Dragonstone now I do
like the sound of this as soon as
Stannis said that there was plenty of
dragonglass
to be mined I have been hoping that
someone would go and get some and once I
saw the photos of John and davos on the
beach of Dragonstone i assumed that was
going to be one of the things that they
would do while they are there and
considering Davos spend some time on
Dragonstone with Stannis I think he
should be able to access some of it
pretty quickly and given everyone some
dragonglass for this mission would be
the smart thing to do everyone should be
armed to the teeth with some of this I
don't know if we're going to give
everybody some but I do think John and
Davos will stock up while they are on
Dragonstone all right now let's move on
to the second half of this scene after a
few minutes of screen time they run into
a white that is walking alone The Hound
tries to tie
way down but it escaped causing the
hound to chase after it the group of
characters corner the white between a
cliff of frozen lake in the woods which
it emerged from the white jumps off the
cliff and as it's falling over the cliff
you can see that there are actually
hundreds of whites climbing up that
cliff and no one can see them coming and
that's when hundreds of more whites
emerge from the woods so now they are
stuck on the edge of this cliff as
whites are climbing up it and whites are
coming straight at them from the woods
holy [ __ ] that sounds intense
then Thoris and Barrack ignite their
swords and begin the attack the whites
on the cliff make it to the top and
start attacking the group from behind or
Commander Ed is killed immediately as
well as several other men from the
Nights Watch white Walker starts to
emerge from the woods and one of them is
riding a giant ice fighter Thoris has
been brutally killed by a zombie polar
bear that seemed to come out of nowhere
the hound tried to save him but was
unsuccessful a white Walker with dual
blade starts to attack Jon Jon ends up
being killed by the white Walker by
being plunged by his sword into the gut
Brienne kills the white Walker without
keeper Jorah then picks up Longclaw
that's laying next to Jon's dead body
and he starts to attack a Brotherhood
without banners member kills a white
Walker with a dragon glass-tipped
Arrowhead Gendry smashes a white face in
with his Warhammer then the nice King
gets off his horse in fights Barrack
with his flaming sword and that's when
Daenerys arrived bones ro gone was
Viserion flying next to them bro ganas
incinerates dozens of whites immediately
which clears the path that allows the
group to escape back to the wall The
Hound subdues a white and takes it with
him as they are about to leave a white
Walker throws a matches ice beer into
drove on which causes him to fly away
erratically the night king then kills
miss Ariane by plunging an ice sword
through his eye Barrack then crawls over
to John's dead body
it gives him the kiss of life Erik drops
dead then John is revived and he picks
up Barracks flaming sword and starts to
kill some white before he ends up being
disarmed once again and right as John is
nearly killed again his uncle Benjen
comes to the rescue to save him
benjin quickly puts Jon on his horse
in whispers goodbye nephew as John rides
away he helplessly watches his Uncle
Benjen get swarmed by dozens of whites
and presumably killed and as the episode
is about to end the night King raises
this Ariane from the dead and rated the
screen is about to fade to black we see
the saralyn's eyes turn blue holy [ __ ]
that was a lot to take in
wow guys I have absolutely no idea if
any of this is going to come through but
goddamn that sounds incredible all right
hold on hold on I'm going to recap this
real quick the group gets surrounded on
a lake as hundreds of whites comes
running out of the woods in front of
them and hundreds of whites are climbing
up the cliff that's directly behind them
Barrack and Thoros ignite their swords
and begin the attack it is killed plus
some other Nights Watch members white
walkers come out of the woods riding
high spiders and zombie polar bears
thor's gets brutally mauled by the polar
bear in a white Walker wielding dual
swords murders Jon Snow
then Brienne comes up with those keeper
and kills the white Walker Jorah picks
up long haul and begins attacking a
brotherhood member shoots an arrow with
a dragonglass tip which kills another
white Walker ginjury starts smashing
whites in the face with a war hammer
Daenerys shows up with her dragons it
starts torching everything then a white
Walker throws a nice beer into drove on
in the night King stabs he was staring
on through the eye turning it into a
zombie dragon Barrack then crawls over
to John and gives him to kiss a life and
dies John gets up picks up his flaming
sword and is almost [ __ ] killed again
but benjin shows up out of nowhere and
sacrifices himself to save John Jesus
Christ that's insane who first off John
dying again and being revived again is
absolutely ridiculous
if someone can come back to life every
damn time they die then that would kind
of take out all the tension and
nervousness whenever they go into battle
if we know they're never going to dies
and that takes out all the fun of not
knowing what's going to happen to them
during war if John does die again it
will probably be in the very last
episode of the series not right here but
other than that I love everything about
this scene it is the most action-packed
scene this show has ever had written for
it
my opinion and if this is fanfiction
they did a hell of a job of making me
excited we do know all these guys are
going to go north of the wall so there
is a chance they do run into some
serious trouble up there berrak has used
a flaming sword before when he fought
the hound
and during the siege of Pyke a belief
forest amir had a sword coated in
wildfire so these two characters
entering a battle with flaming swords
isn't crazy and we know that gentry has
a Warhammer thanks to the leaked photos
and old nan did mention ice fighters
before so I wouldn't be surprised if we
did see them so I don't know guys what
do you guys think about this you get as
excited as I do when you hear something
like this in the books
berrak does give lady Catelyn the kiss
of life which turns her into Lady
Stoneheart
so all of this stuff is based off of
things that are true to the story so
none of this sounds too crazy to me I
just don't like the part about John
dying again my comment below and tell me
what you think about this I absolutely
love it
but I want to know how you guys feel so
thanks for taking the time to listen to
this you know I always appreciate it and
I will see you guys down in the comments
section let's talk about this [ __ ] bye
guys